hi everyone I am ank and welcome to this
fantastic video on top AI certification
for 2024 by simply learn but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these type
of videos and find them interesting
subscribe to our YouTube channel as we
bring you the best videos daily also hit
the Bell icon to never miss any update
from Simply enough so let's get started
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence AI has emerged as a
transformative technology that is
revolutioning various aspects of our
lives with its ability to simulate human
intelligence and perform complex tasks
AI has found application in the field
ranging from Healthcare Finance to
transportation and entertainment and
many other fields so let me share you
some fascinating stats with you that
illustrate the impact of the potential
of this game changing technology before
we delve into the fascinating world of
artificial intelligence so according to
Glassdoor the average salary of AI
engineer is 160 thousand dollars in
United States and in India it's up to 11
lakh per annum in India
so learning AI offers numerous benefits
ranging from career opportunities and
Innovation to personal growth and
ethical consideration it equips you with
valuable skills and knowledge that can
have profound impact on various aspects
of society and the World At Large but
before choosing the right course to
excel in the field of AI can be
challenging so with so many options
available out there in the market how do
you know which one is the right for you
well we are here to help you without any
further Ado let's discuss the top AI
certification for 2024. number one on
the list is post Gadget program in Ai
and machine learning this postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM offered you by simply learn is an
online program designed you to provide
students with a comprehensive
understanding of AI and machine learning
Concepts tools and techniques these
programs cover various topics such as
data science stat deep learning computer
vision and NLP natural language
processing and help you gain the right
skills on a various tools such as Keras
matplotlift tensorflow Django and many
more furthermore the curriculum is
structured around interactive online
class live session with industry expert
and Hands-On projects the program also
includes access to simple as learning
management system which provide a
student with additional resources such
as practicing exercise quizzes and
simulation overall the Purdue post
Gadget program in Ai and machine
learning offered by simply learn is a
well-structured and comprehensive
program that can help a student gain
expertise in Ai and machine learning
Concepts and enhance their careers
Prospect in the field upon completing
the program student will receive a post
graduate certificate from Purdy
University and IBM indicating that they
have acquired the skills and knowledge
necessary to apply Ai and machine
learning Concept in the real world
situation admission to this post Gadget
program in AIML course requires two plus
years of experience preferred bachelor
degree with an average of 50 percent or
a high amount basic understanding of
programming concept and Mathematics so
hurry up enroll now in the Purdue
postgraduate program in AIML and create
your own successful career the course
link is in the description box below
number two number two on the list is IIT
kanpur professional certificate course
in Ai and machine learning accelerate
your career in Ai and ml without
comprehensive professional certificate
course in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with IIT kanpur this
machine learning course will equip with
highly coveted skill in ml deep learning
NLP generative AI prompt engineering
chair gbt and much more through live
classes by industry expert master
classes from IIT khanbo faculty and
Hands-On projects you will stay ahead in
the field of AI this AI ml course covers
Concepts like machine learning deep
learning natural language processing
reinforcement learning computer vision
speech recognition generative ai
explainable ai prompt engineering chat
Jeopardy and much more this is date of
art of machine learning course covers
modules that can help you Kickstart a
thriving career in AIML you will also
receive the opportunity to delve into
Cutting Edge AI topics such as
generative AI charity GPT models and
explainable I for admission to this
artificial intelligence course candidate
should have a bachelor degree with an
average of 50 or higher marks preferably
two plus years of experience
prior knowledge or experience in
programming and Mathematics so why vet
enroll now and unlock exciting AIML
opportunities so why wait join our seats
are feeling fast the course link is in
the description box below number third
on the list is AIML bootcamp by Caltech
this AIML bootcamp program May develop
your career as an expert in artificial
Intel and machine learning bootcamp in
the collaboration with Caltech
University the AIML bootcamp offers
master classes by Celtic professors live
classes taught by industry experts
interactive labs and projects relevant
to this industry this bootcamp offers
Caltech academic Excellence simply runs
career resistance campus immersion and
hands-on experience this AIML bootcamp
will help you get noticed but top hiring
companies and helps you in the industry
relevant Capstone project the AIML
bootcamp at Caltech is the best option
for anyone wishing to get a Competitive
Edge in the era of Cutting Edge
Technologies this bootcamp offers
complete understanding of AI based
Technologies like machine learning
natural language processing deep
learning speech recognition
reinforcement learning and much more
this course covers tools and techniques
like python tensorflow Keras matplotlib
and manimo along with industry projects
like social media and e-commerce
manufacturing attack Healthcare and many
more Amazing projects choosing the boot
camp can get you hired by the renowned
companies like Microsoft Google IBM
Amazon Samsung and Adobe this bootcamp
has benefited many aspiring AIML
engineers and professional candidate
applying for AIML bootcamp should have
the following this boot camp is for the
United States only
be at least 18 years old and have a high
school diploma or equivalent have prior
knowledge or experience in programming
and Mathematics preferably two plus
years of formal work experience so hurry
up and roll now in the AI and ml boot
camp and create your own successful
career the course link is in the
description box below finally we have
Masters in artificial intelligence
program this master program in
artificial intelligence is one of the
most sought after courses offered by
simpler this artificial intelligence
sponsor program in collaboration with
IBM introduces a student to Blended
learning and prepares them to be a
specialist in Ai and data science this
program will teach you the necessary
skills you need to become an AI expert
and land in your dream job this course
covers the basic fundamental of Python
programming languages and its popular
averages like numpy and pandas from
scratch to some Advanced topic like
machine learning algorithm deep learning
natural language processing computer
vision and AI deployment by covering
some important tools like Keras
tensorflow PSI by and many more so what
else you can expect from this program
well this course also includes three
Capstone and 12 industry relevant
projects from the likes of Amazon
Walmart Mercedes-Benz Uber and many more
immersive learning experience it takes
higher in life interaction in the live
AI online classes delivered by seasoned
trainers and Industry expert and simply
learn job assist programs sound
interesting right so what are you
waiting for don't miss out on this
chance to take career to the next level
and role in our artificial intelligence
master program course today and start
your journey to become AI expert the
link is added in the description box
below and the comment section moving
forward let's see the future of AI the
future of AI whole tremendous promising
and potential as technology advances AI
is expected to become more sophisticated
and capable some key trends that will
shape the future of AI include ethical
AI emphasis on fear transparent and
unbiased AI system grows with efforts of
address privacy accountability and
biases ethical concerns Drive regulation
and responsible AI development AI in
robotics integrating with AI robotics
create intelligent robots for complex
tasks in manufacturing Logistics and
Healthcare
a i in iot a I combined with iot and a
versus smart home cities and industries
enhancing decision making and automation
through interconnected devices AI in
personalization AI enhanced personalized
experience in entertainment e-commerce
and marketing by understanding user
preferences and delivering tailored
recommendations the fifth one is
autonomous system self-driving cars
drones and Robotics Advance relying on
AI algorithms and sensor transforming
Transportation logistic and other
industry rather than replacing humans AI
is expected to augment it human
capabilities and enable more effective
collaboration AI system can assist in
decision making automated repetitive
tasks and provide personalized
recommendations allowing humans to focus
on higher level tasks that require
creativity and critical thinking with
that we have come to end of this video
on AI certification for 2024. I hope you
found it valuable and entertaining
please ask any questions about the
topics covered in this video in the
comment section below a team of experts
will assist you as soon as possible
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning with simply learn staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you